-Today is Friday,
and that's usually when
I catch up on
some personal stuff --
you know, I check my inbox,
return some e-mails,
and then, of course,
I send out thank you notes.
And I was running
a bit behind today.
I thought
if you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out my weekly
thank you notes right now.
Is that okay with you?
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
[ Gentle music plays ]
♪♪
-You think he had
that Nyquil chicken?
-Yeah, I don't know.
He just seems sleepy.
-Wow. Real sleepy.
-A little sleepy tonight, yeah.
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, candy apples,
for combining the joys
of eating something sweet
with the opportunity to
break all of my teeth.
[ Applause ]
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you,
"Don't Worry Darling,"
for being a gripping drama
full of twists and turns...
and the movie looks good, too.
[ Applause ]
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, clear recycling bags,
or as I like to call you,
trash aquariums.
[ Applause ]
-Oh, an apple core.
-I like that one.
[ Gentle music plays ]
This one's a thinker.
-This one's a thinker?
-Yeah, I just thought --
-This isn't...
-I thought of it now,
but this one's a thinker.
-'Cause you're thinking of these
on the spot.
-Correct.
-You're just writing your
weekly gratitude list right now,
so the one you just thought of
is a thinker?
Okay.
-The one I thought of,
about to write, is a thinker.
-Yeah. Not pre-written.
-No, no.
I'm writing them now
with ink from this
[Rolling Rs] herrre pen.
-Yes.
-[ Clears throat loudly ]
-La plume.
-Mm, la plume.
-Le crayon.
[ Gentle music plays ]
-Thank you, waffles,
for being squares in triangles
in circles.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Niceeee.
Euclid said, A plus.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gentle music plays, stops ]
-Is this one a thinker too?
Or no?
-What's that? No.
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, new Star Wars show,
"Andor,"
for sounding like someone
at Disney Plus ran out of names.
"Uh, it's about...
spaceships and/or, uh..."
[ Laughter ]
"Droids and/or..."
-Star Wars, right?
[ Gentle music plays ]
-Thank you, boba, for combining
the taste of tea
with the thrill of accidentally
choking on a tapioca ball.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-[ Gagging ]
[ Coughing ]
-There you go.
-Bubble tea.
-Mm.
[ Gentle music plays ]
Thank you, pumpkins,
for being a 360-degree butt.
[ Laughter ]
[ Rim shot plays ]
Come on, man. Come on.
-Come on! Grow up!
-Come on. Come on.
-Grow up!
[ Laughter ]
[ Gentle music plays ]
-Thank you, soup, for not
going by your original name,
"a hot, pureed salad."
There you have it, everybody.
Those are our thank you notes.